this is Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky we
are watching German Grandmaster Georg
Meyer taking on the world champion
Magnus Carlson at the 2014 feed 8 World
Blitz Championship Meyer is an
incredibly solid Grandmaster with years
of experience at the highest level he
might not be 2700 but he is not an easy
opponent in Blitz and classical he
starts the game with a solid opening the
king's Indian attack with the pawn
appearing on C4 this is sort of a
mixture between an English opening and a
king's Indian attack one of the most
solid openings in existence and Magnus
responds with kind of a semi-slav setup
positioning his Bishop between that pawn
triangle this is also a reputable way
for black to respond to the king's
Indian attack and georgmeyer the first
to take a significant thing as he's
probably trying to decide where he wants
to position his Knight on Buenas you
want to bring it out to C3 or as is more
typical in these positions is the Knight
going to come out to D2 supporting its
brother on F3 and then the dark squid
Bishop is often fincheted on B3 but no
Meyer takes a third route he plays Queen
B3 harassing magnus's Pawn on B7 the
goal of course is to induce black to
push the pawn to B6 that would create
significant weaknesses on the queen side
Magnus of course will not oblige instead
he moves his Queen up to E7 a nice
Square for black screen and of course it
defends the pawn on B7 Bishop G5 I like
that response from York Meyer the idea
is to capture the Knight on F6 Black's
Queen is suddenly feeling rather
uncomfortable and you can see a little
bit of consternation there from Magnus
Carlson as he brings his Knight out to
A6 the reason he couldn't bring his
Knight to D7 is because that would slice
off the connection between the black
queen and the pawn on B7 so he has to
find alternate arrangements for his
Knight georgmeyer decides not to rush
with Bishop takes F6 even though that
would have forced Magnus to recapture it
with the pawn but the bishop pair is a
significant asset in these types of
positions and Carlson a roundabout way
indeed it took two stopovers he had to
fly through Atlanta and Chicago but he
finally made it to D7 while chasing
White's Queen away from B3 and this is
sort of an ideal setup now for black
with the Knights connected to each other
uh so are white snides but I don't think
York Meyer has gotten all that much here
out of the opening he also faces down a
30 second time deficit maybe he should
have grabbed that Knight on F6 while he
had a chance and he tries to mix things
up by pushing his Pawn up to E4 grabbing
control of the center the drawbacks of
this move are pretty obvious though he
is creating weaknesses in the center of
the square on D4 is often a problem for
writing these types of positions and
Magnus Carlsen takes the Knight on F3 an
interesting positional decision there
trading giving away his light squared
Bishop but earning himself the E5 Square
potentially for his Knight maybe for a
pawn and he closes the center with D4
this is a really interesting decision
making for the world champion dorkmeyer
brings his light squared Bishop back to
its initial fiancarode square and will
Carlson play H6 that would then Force
essentially Force white to trade on F6
otherwise the bishop would get would get
trapped with uh E6 E5 and so georgmeyer
obliges he trades on F6 and now we have
a very interesting middle game the
center is closed we've got opposite
colored Bishops and when you hear that
term you often think draw but not in a
middle game opposite colored Bishops
tend to lead to drawish and games but
with a lot of other pieces on the board
they actually produce some of the most
exciting middle games in chess and York
Meyer taking another significant chunk
of time as he falls below 90 seconds
will he push his F Pawn up to F4 no he
instead plays a rather modest move Rook
a to C1 may be preparing to push his C
Pawn to C5 and carve out the C4 Square
for his Knight Carlson says no you are
not playing C5 he brings his Knight back
to D7 and now contests the center with
E5 and georgmeyer locks up now the king
side with F5 but it seems to me that
really black is the only one with
chances here as Carlson grabs space on
the queen side his Pawn is now on A4 and
it restricts the Knight on D to even
further it now can no longer move on to
B3 and Carlson with King E8 to d8 the
reason he didn't Castle queenside is
because that would drop the pawn on A4
he has to keep his Rook on A8 in order
to make contact with that A4 Pawn but he
has found an excellent Square for his
King on C7 that King is completely
watertight it is fully safe but for the
time being so is White's king the big
question here is going to be who is
going to open the position up and where
is the position going to open up black
of course wants to open up the king side
eventually in order to get to white skin
and the way that magnets could try to do
that is to prepare the Breakthrough G7
G6 but if he does that too fast then he
gives up control over the f file and
that strategy could backfire Carlson of
course known for his just filigree
Precision in these types of closed
positions he is infinitely patient and I
think we're going to see Carlson slowly
preparing King side expansion slowly
preparing G7 G6 or maybe even G5 Carlson
taking his time deciding on his next
course of action the position is very
locked up but I have a feeling that this
game is not going to end in a draw in
the next couple of moves Carlson is
going to keep trying York Meyer is
basically fully passive he just has to
wait around for black to make progress
on the king side because York simply
cannot open up the queen side Carlson is
too much in control with that pawn on A4
and that Bishop on C5 controlling all of
the key dark squares if white plays B3
then black can simply lock up the queen
side with A3 or open up the a file with
a takes B3 now Carlson he's taken a
significant amount of time as both
players are now right at about one
minute and there's that G5 move Carlson
decides not to wait any further a risky
decision G5 leading to an onpass on the
f-file has opened and who is going to
benefit from that that's the big
question currently white has a rook on
F1 but black I think Carlson is about to
bring one of his own Rooks to the app
file we could get a mass trade of Rooks
and maybe even a trade of Queens on the
file and if that happens then I think
the game is going to start moving closer
to a draw Carlson plays A3 on his own
volition a very interesting move
inducing B3 and look at those dark
Square weaknesses on the queen side
Bishop B4 worming knifing his way into
those dark squares that Bishop could
park itself on C3 if it so desires but
you know it looks nice but it's not
actually going to attack anything the
one positive for Meyer here is that all
of his pawns are on light squares they
cannot be attacked but later on in the
game Carlson could try to get his knight
from F6 over to C5 and you could
Envision some end games where he might
have some sacrifices on the B3 Pawn in
order to pave the way for his a pawn to
promote but that's very far in the
future because all of the heavy pieces
are still on the board and georgmeyer
has built up a triple stack on the f
file he has moved his Queen into F2
attacking magnus's Knight on F6 and
Carlson might not have expected that
move as he leans back in his chair
showing a little bit of frustration
where is he going to move his Knight he
moves it all the way back to E8
dorkmeyer has beautifully positioned his
lights squid Bishop on H3 to restrict
the knight's access to C5 and we have a
trade of Rooks will we also have a trade
of Queens yes we will Meyer takes back
with his Rook his Rook is now in the
seventh rank but it doesn't really have
anything to attack will he bring his
Knight into the game he does Knight H2
2g4 attacking E5 forcing Carlson's
Bishop back to D6 and all of a sudden
Carlson is on the defensive it seems
that his strategy to open up the file
may have backfired but the one big
problem here for the German Grandmaster
is that he doesn't really have any
Targets to attack and he moves the
Knight back to H2 Carlson starts the
long journey over to the C5 Square ooh
and I think Meyer might have
underestimated that if Black's Knight
appears on C5 or B4 then white will have
major problems defending both the D3
pawn and the A2 Pawn at the same time
and Carlson Rook h8 to d8 he sacrifices
his entire King side all Magnus Carlson
cares about is getting his Knight to B4
and winning the pawn on A2 because if he
does his a-pawn is going to promote Rook
takes G6 by Meyer he's got 10 seconds I
don't think York Meyer sees a defense
the night before and I don't see a
defense either he brings his his night
out to G4 but his pawns are so much
lower C5 check but this is desperation
by the German Grandmaster Carlson has
taken back with his King and that A2
Pawn is about to fall and once it falls
I don't see a way for white to contain
Black's pass or Bishop p8 though by
Magnus Carlsen so patient as he moves
his pieces back Meyer's still trying to
create some Shenanigans he had a fork
threat on E6 but Carlson carefully
brought his King back and now
positioning his Rook on h8 to fully
contain White's connected passers on the
king side there goes the A2 Pawn Meyer
has no choice but to bring his Rook back
to F1 he has to try to stop Black's a
pawn from promoting and now he's lost
the d-pawn as well but that Rook on F1
is for the time being doing a pretty
good job of stopping Black from queening
Meyer desperately trying to bring his
own pawns up as quickly as possible but
Bishop before an amazing move by Magnus
white can't stop Bishop C3 and then the
Apon will promote Meyer loses on time
what a display by the world champion and
if you like this video make sure to
click the link in the playlist for more
of these videos thank you so much for
watching
thank you